[Music]
you guys just celebrated the 30th
anniversary of the started we're just
we're hammering whole a home this old
thing aren't we you're 66 Pam thirty
years ago you were hot BAM I didn't say
that he said that svet solace it's such
an iconic it's probably one of the most
iconic television shows of all time and
it's been 30 years no we had this
reunion and it was the writers and the
actors and everyone got together and it
was really sweet but before the dinner
we decided to let Entertainment Tonight
come in because an interview us because
we had come up at the same time at
Paramount Studios cheers and
entertainers started at the same time
yeah so in came this very sweet lady and
was interviewing and in our defense it
was noisy it was loud but she she kept
saying like do you think there'll be a
cheers reunion show and you saw a bunch
of people in their sixties right what
what did she say what did she say horse
walks into a bar people have those giant
ears
wow you uh you've talked remember did
you talk about it over the years but
you're you'd have a rivalry on the set
with Woody Harrelson sort of because
Woody Harrelson started out on cheers xx
much younger guy yeah he we were all 37
when he came on and he was twenty-five
and thirty sevens about when you
realized you're no longer 25 and we we
tried to beat him at everything
basketball it kicked our bud I remember
uh Johnny Ratzenberger leg wrestled him
BAM you know what he killed him I uh
to this day my arm has a little
tendinitis from trying not to lose to
him chess everything he just cleaned our
clock so he's the guy we love too if
there's a practical joke you want to
pull it on woody otherwise it's wasted
who cares you want to get woody do you
feel that you ever beat him did you ever
get the better of him and anything I did
I did there was a when we are in our
heyday
people would come watches audiences
would come watch us rehearse not just
the show night but rehearse and we were
rehearsing and everyone is saying woody
and the cast for God's sakes man wear
some underwear he was in sweatpants you
know it was like come on you know that's
ridiculous
jocks or something he didn't he was just
going commando going commando and he at
one point in in the story his character
leaps up on a desk and goes hey
everybody give me your attention there's
an audience like this watching and is
just like oh I have to do this hand down
his sweatpants and he was horrified and
probably rehearsing he was a little
nervous so you know he was doubly
horrible well they did get me back they
did get me back I was a year later he
waited a year later I was in the shower
and George said leave the door unlocked
so I can come in and shave we're all
late so his joy when I left the door the
door slams open woody rips open the
shower door and Kirstie's there of the
Polaroid and I was immortalized for the
for the rap show video the end of the
year video that we showed everybody yeah
where's that picture now I have it
framed
I have wallet size